parliament will lay out its demands on
how online platforms and marketplaces
should be regulated
meps will also propose rules on
artificial intelligence which should
promote innovation
while maintaining high ethical standards
green and sustainable farming is
essential for europe's food security
and its climate change goals parliaments
will set its position on the proposed
reform of the common agricultural policy
due to begin next year meps will debate
the conclusions of the latest eu
summit the agenda included the evolution
of the kovit 19 pandemic
the climate emergency brexit
negotiations
and eu relations with africa
parliaments will make recommendations on
the eu's relationship with belarus
following the disputed elections
including new free and fair elections
and sanctions like asset freezes on
president alexander lukashenka
and his regime parliament's president
will announce the winner of this year's
sakharov prize
the finalists for the human rights award
of the democratic opposition in belarus
environmental activists from honduras
and the archbishop of mosul
you